Have you seen those patch products where they say they're using frequencies to help people with all sorts of problems?
I was skeptical, but I know someone who has was allergic to everything.
It had several issues, and now she's better.
Yes, I have heard of those two.
We have used them.
We've had them with our store different times, but we don't carry them currently.
And I do think that they have efficacy.
They can't argue with a lot of the testimonials that are out there of people that said they thought that it really helped them.
So, I think there can be benefit to them, but just to chose again how frequencies can be beneficial to you.
And I think really how that works, I think, well, how does the patch actually put out frequencies?
I think what the patch does is it's doing similar to the phone things, is that you are exposed to frequencies, and it changes those to be beneficial frequencies for you.
No, again, I've had some people that have used those and say that it doesn't help them at all, but you could hear that about everybody too.
But I do think it can have efficacy, I think it can have benefits.